well this is a very significant
breakthrough because it's broken the
deadlock really and the standoff between
their baroness Hallett lady Hallett the
retired appeal court judge and the
government in particular and also Boris
Johnson over the handing over of all
this material that she wants for the
inquiry primarily a lot of diary entries
and WhatsApp messages now
um there was the battle between the
cabinet office in particular and Lady
Hallett had looked as though it was
heading for the the courts and a legal
battle now Mr Johnson here has said look
it's not me that's holding things up
it's the government with this dramatic
statement in the last few minutes he
says that all his material
whatsapps notebooks requested by the
inquiry have been handed to the cabinet
office in full in full and in unredacted
form now this really is putting a chat
is a challenge to the cabinet office to
the Prime Minister and other senior
government ministers to hand them over
to baroness Hallett exactly as they are
now he goes on to say that he urges the
cabinet office to disclose them to the
inquiry so this is Boris Johnson really
catching the cabinet office a bit off
guard probably the last development we
had late last night or during the course
of the evening certainly was the cabinet
office in a very hard-hitting statement
saying no we are not going to hand over
all the whatsapps and diary entries
because a lot of them are as they put it
irrelevant and contain the private
private lives of many government staff
official officials and employees employ
government employees are entitled to a
private life the cabinet office said in
its statement so
um Mr Johnson is saying that the cabinet
office has had access to this material
for several months several months not
just a few weeks or so several months so
this is really Mr Johnson throwing down
a challenge to Rishi sunak and indeed
Oliver Dowden who is the minister in
charge of the cabinet office
um
he said and he also in a challenge to
the government has said this he would
immediately disclose his material
directly to the inquiry if asked so the
ball really is in the government's court
now because Boris Johnson has moved
swiftly ahead of the next deadline the
four B 4 pm deadline tomorrow uh to uh
to assist the inquiry and you might say
embarrass rissy sunak and the government
now he says that he understands the
government's position that position
being that some of the materials
irrelevant and that handing everything
over could be harmful for government
business in the future and be unfair to
employees because it would include
material it was nothing to do with their
work
um he doesn't he's perfectly happy for
the inquiry to have access to the
material in whatever form it requires he
is sis he said this before that he's
cooperated with the inquiry in full from
the beginning and continues to do so he
points he reminds everyone he
established the inquiry when he was
prime minister a year or two ago he was
the one who announced the inquiry under
pressure from among others the lib Dem
leader sir Ed Davey and indeed the
bereaved families who have been very
critical of the government for the way
they've appeared to be reluctant to hand
over material he looks forward to
continuing to assist the inquiry with
its important work so this is a blow
struck by Boris Johnson against those
who claim that he's holding things up
that he's involved in some sort of
cover-up and the pressure now will be on
Rishi sunak and the government to act to
hand over Mr Johnson's material
whatsapp's diary entries and so on or
he's going to do so himself now there
are those that the claim that the
government has actually been using Mr
Johnson as a sort of a defense mechanism
because what they really want to do is
protect WhatsApp messages diary entries
and so on the senior ministers like the
former Chancellor exchequer and now
prime minister Rishi sunak Michael Gove
and others who are involved in all that
covered planning a year or two ago so
decisive blow struck by Boris Johnson
here it's now over to Mr sunac and the
senior members of the government to
respond by handing over the inquiry at
the material to the inquiry we are well
ahead of that deadline tomorrow but this
is a really significant uh breakthrough
and possibly it means that the standoff
will not uh will not result now in legal
action if the government does decide to
pursue a judicial review as they've been
threatening to do well Boris Johnson can
now hold his hands up and say well look
I've handed everything over it's the
government that's being obstructive and
guilty of her cover up it's not me so a
decisive move here by Boris Johnson
and the big question as you say John is
what the cabinet office do next the
deadline is four o'clock tomorrow
afternoon isn't it and they have all
along held to this line that they didn't
need to hand over anything that was in
their words I think unambiguously
irrelevant to the inquiry and they would
argue that lots of these conversations
have nothing to do with covid but why is
it that a baroness Hallett is so Keen to
see them
well her argument is that look you asked
me to hold this inquiry I'll decide
what's relevant and what's not it's not
for you the government to decide what's
relevant yes that phrase we've heard a
lot in the last 24 hours
unambiguously uh irrelevant material uh
that's the charge she her argument is I
we will sift through all the material
decides what's relevant and that's why
they want it all the government is
arguing as it did in a a pretty
hard-hitting statement last night uh
that uh these uh what's that material
this what's that material includes stuff
that has nothing to do with covet it's
private stuff it's personal stuff it's
not work related and as I say in the
statement last night they actually said
government employees are entitled to a
private life well it does look as though
from what's on the face of it uh Boris
Johnson is uh prepared to let his
personal life be laid bare he's had so
we are told he's handing over all the
material the this really does put
pressure now on the governments on Rishi
sunak in particular and Oliver Dowd and
his Deputy who let's not forget has been
accused by Boris Johnson and his
supporters of uh having what has been
described as having form in trying to
damage Mr Johnson remember when the
conservatives lost two by-elections very
badly
um Mr Dowden sensationally quit as Tory
chairman uh in the early hours of the
morning I remember it well it was about
6 a.m and of course that led later to
the resignations of Sajid Javid and
arishi sunak in what was an absolute
bombshell it was that was the beginning
of the end for Boris Johnson's
Premiership there is distrust between Mr
Johnson and Mr sunac earlier this week
we were told that the two of them were
going to have a phone call this week to
perhaps try and clear the air smooth
things over there going to talk about
the contentious issue of Boris Johnson's
resignation honors list but also
obviously how to approach the covid
inquiry now that phone call it appears
is now not going to happen partly we're
told because Mr Johnson didn't want Mr
Dowden the head of the cabinet office
and Deputy Prime Minister in on the call
so Boris Johnson has decided to strike
he has handed over his material and it
really is now up to the government how
they respond if they do persist with
that saying no we're not going to hand
over all this material we're going to go
for a judicial review well the
opposition parties as they have done
already in the past 24 hours politicians
like Angela Raynor were streeting and uh
Daisy Cooper for the liberal Democrats
they will cry cover up where streeting
said Mr sunac was being slippery last
night uh Angela rain has talked about
the government having something to hide
and a cover-up and a daisy Cooper came
out with the colorful claim that the
government was using the dog ate my
homework excuse for not coming up with
all the material baroness Hallett has
demanded so we await the response from
the cabinet office